okay yes can't vet me man okay okay so
I'm going to change the topic a little
bit so
um
with modern women the epidemic is that
even with birth control
we're getting more abortions than ever
does if a girl gets an abortion does
that take her out of the wife category
100 Why million percent
complete moral misalignment okay
it's a fetus no I'm very very strongly
pro-life so tell me why no absolutely
not tell you why yeah yeah why a woman
who can happily kill her own child
when she was a victim of grape
that's less than that's fewer than one
percent fewer than one person let's talk
about the 99 yeah yeah why is it why is
it that whenever a dude makes a point we
always got to bring up the exception as
well it's not even a common exception
that's quite a common thing for women to
experience no no it's not no it's not
well it happens but it's not common it's
great it's not great not necessarily
pregnancy for great but grape in general
is no it's not no that's my job I deal
with them plants every single day so
what's the percentage looking like
I think that's because that's your job
that's your job so you get to see them a
concentration but if you look in the
whole of the UK yeah you see that but if
you're a minority
no I'm saying like if you if you look at
Stats that's not true it's not the
majority of women it's actually a very
small percentage because otherwise we're
just going off of he said she said and
she can say anything if it was a
majority then most of these people I'm
not saying the majority of women have
experienced grape I'm saying there's
quite a large percentage of women that
have experienced it but no not
not statistically it's not it's not the
large majority well it's a mind it's a
very small minority I'm not gonna lie to
you yet just being super real and
understanding about the life that we're
trying to live now and what like the
status of the world is
I mean as long as you're willing to deal
with the consequences of your choices my
friend save yourself and save your child
because sometimes you get into an
accident with somebody that is
definitely not the man that you need to
be having a child with and you're
definitely not in the right space of
mine so instead of you putting like a
child into your chaotic well just you
know be more responsible he's not kill
it but like before he gets to a stage
where he's like super gone like you at
the at the end of the day now you got
the option of like taking a little bit
of control if that puts bad energy into
the universe deal with the consequences
but at the end of the day you'd rather
do that than to like bring a traumatized
child into the world I actually have a
question do you think that uh poor kids
are less valuable than rich kids because
you know when you think about it we're
all rich because most people in all of
human history have been even poor people
are richer than most people were in all
of history I would say that that's
definitely not true because I I'm
African I know what what like what it
means to be poor and still be he happens
to be privileged and blessed what I do
mean is for example there are people
that just not in the in the best state
of mind or even in a relationship that
could be supportive of bringing a
healthy citizen into this world and then
if people don't have this sort of
control it gets to a stage where
everybody's going to be messed up
because their parents are making
mistakes the end of the day instead of
us judging abortions let's just first
deal with sexual education sexual
discipline and then we can avoid
abortions other than that
we're talking about taking a human life
here no we're talking about we're taking
control of something that actually
hasn't got to that stage yet it depends
on how you feel about it but it's not
feelings you're if literally take it you
can sugarcoat it how you want it's the
taking of an innocent human life
to an extent it depends
okay okay you can have your feelings
about it I'm just saying that's
literally what it is let's move away
from euphemisms and feelings that is
what it is
to both women together
when I first came to the show remember I
said to you there's not a situation that
I haven't experienced you remember I
said that churches ago now I was in a
relationship I was young I was 16 and I
wouldn't say I got put into relationship
a very abusive relationship and I had a
child through grape
I was 17. I was on the pill
so 17 I couldn't say I had loads of
money because I was still living at home
and as far as I'm concerned I had my
child
at 17 years old no money and I worked
and I kept my child and when everybody
keeps on talking about grape and abuse
yes Pearl I did report it right had it
down in Junctions and everything I still
got my child
everybody was against it because in
those days I built shame on the Family
but nobody knew why I had my child
and to this day I've still got one child
because I was only able to have one
child and because I don't believe in
abortion
and I was a Foster carer and I fostered
and looked after 10 children as a single
parent
and I don't care how poor you are I
don't care what situation you're in
unless your life is in danger I still
don't believe in abortion can I say
something and I was on the pill uh
there's there's a thing there's certain
people there's it's just like a luck of
the draw there are there's people that
are extremely blessed that the situation
and they're actually blessed with a with
a mother that will take care of you from
whatever situation make you be a
wholesome human being and show you all
the Love on the flip side there are
people that then go on to abuse their
children because they don't know any
better they're people that go to neglect
their children because they're not in a
supportive relationship or because they
can't handle it if you realize because
because I said I said I was a foster
carer I was a Foster carer and I
fostered 10 children those children
you're talking about and they had better
lives for it because you're the only
person to have you and I only foster
children primary school age so I had
children that have been abused
physically and sexually at that age so
nobody can't give me the excuse use I
mean that's your opinion I'm giving you
my experience so as far as I'm concerned
if the care system that allows these
women to have the children that allows
these women to have abortions they also
allow these children to have that allow
these women to have the children and
hand them over to responsible people
that will look after and nurture and
care for those children rather than
murder them because people murder their
children too often and then those who
don't get murdered I look after I look
after I raise I nurture and I look after
them and I'm sure there's there's
African children indian children white
children out there that I've fostered
that have been to University being
models and having good stable lives
because of me so I'd rather even at my
age now
I would rather look after somebody
else's child I'd look after children
that have been sexually abused at two
and three years old I have had them and
I'd rather have them knowing that I
looked after them
then they got murdered and as far as I'm
concerned it's not the it's not these
children it's Society
and if the people are messed up people
are out there having sexual lessons and
in school they don't teach them
parenting lessons skills like cooking
skills managing money and that's what
the people need because there's no
poverty I'm going to be the one saying
there's no poverty in England England
you get paid to have children it's the
parents and the people that have the
money that are mismanaging it so rather
than go out there and say oh this is a
poor person this look at what they're
doing manage their money because I
guarantee you those children
who come from those households look the
parents are smoking
they can afford to smoke they can smoke
a food smart screen TV they can afford
jewelry the children have got all the
latest phones and tablets and everything
but yet they're going to say there's
poverty because they have no food they
have no clothes it's not to do with the
government it's to do with them managing
their money so as far as I'm concerned
no child deserves to be killed unless
the mother's gonna die may I say
something auntie I appreciate what
you're saying it's a very touchy topic
because obviously it's it's sensitive I
believe that children to me are one of
the purest things in the world and if it
gets to a stage where actually you have
a choice either terminate this life
right here right now the energy is still
in the world the energy still exists but
Terminator now instead of a lot of
playing with chance of letting a child
go into the system and become an
extremely wounded human being I'd rather
do the other because you'll go to a
better place the same way I believe in
euthanasia is the same way I believe in
abortion oh gosh obviously that's
different because this is
I don't believe in any furthermore
murder so that's why we're always going
to differ that's why we're always going
to agree right because anyway
I want to hear what the rest of what you
had to say zooby I didn't hear your
opinion yeah finish your opinion yeah
well like we wouldn't work right so
that's the answer to the question very
clearly that's a complete morality I
said maybe to you it's a complete moral
misalignment right like everything
you've just said there that's freaking
horrifying can I ask and I'm not
disagreeing with you zubi can I ask why
you don't support killing people yeah no
well I used to be a [ __ ] so I'm with you
but can I support why you don't uh can I
can I I just want to know I don't get to
talk to people that have always varying
different opinions all the time because
we live in Echo chambers of course so
I'm very interested and I'm not that I
disagree I'm very interested in why you
don't believe in abortion outside of the
they're killing people because we kill
people with tons of other things but
what is the thing about abortion very
simple I think it I think it is wrong to
intentionally terminate an innocent
human life yeah period that's it
I think it's a crime to corruption
I would never been able to have another
child again and I would have been
childless and I was on the pill but I
would have never had a child again and
you know what when I got pregnant I
actually told I had a old Aunt well she
was a you know like Auntie and I went to
her and I said to her two people I told
first my stepdad
and that aren't and I went to her and I
said
explain to us that I'm pregnant and she
sat me down and she said and this is in
the old days and she said Jennifer she
said I've been seeing this married man
for years
and you know like when you get them
women back in the day that they would
that was the woman and he and she said
and I got I got pregnant she goes and he
said to me it's either me
or the child
and this man was everything to where her
world took her out they went places and
she said I decided to choose my child
and she said to me when I was having the
child there were complications and she
said I'll never be able to have another
child
and she's only got one son she goes we
have your child and exactly what
happened to what happened to me and I
got the one child
well I'm I'm not gonna lie I can
sympathize when I speak before I want
sympathy I I I I O2 was in a very
complicated relationship I put it as
that and I was in that same situation
and I just determinate you know why
because I said listen I would rather
take that risk than to create do that
for my child because this person is
definitely not going to be a good father
to my child I already vetted the
situation and if he gets to a point
where I can't have any children I'll do
an alternative I Will Bless other souls
and give my love and my energy to
somebody that is not even my child
regardless of whatever happens whether I
can have children or not I'll still
bless people I'll still give love I will
still be able to be a mother even if
biologically that was my not my Meant To
Be My Destiny that's it you can always
find alternatives to things but one
thing that I believe that we should do
is ensure that whatever energy we bring
to or whatever child children we're
raising we're gonna put them in a
situation where they can be better human
beings otherwise Society is going to to
whatever that's why the situation is now
what they are in England it's very easy
like for people to have children when
they're teenagers look at how everybody
is acting now it's very easy because the
majority of abortions are not from
teenagers No in fact it's actually from
women no and what I'm saying is in the
UK I think the UK is actually the
country in Europe that has the highest
rate of teenage pregnancy and you can
see actually how that's affecting
Society there needs to be a certain way
of controlling this type of of I would
say unhealed traumatized kind of
DNA to keep passing on if you're not
ready to have a child then you can
recognize that you have a choice to
either make the situations worse for you
and the fact an innocent child or take
the chance now and make it better if you
means you don't have kids again save
somebody else's child go faster go adopt
there's too many people that needing
your love why don't you give it up for
adoption because giving it up for
adoption you're putting your child in a
situation where actually you can follow
either side of Statistics either going
to be with an angel person or you're
going to be with the devil that's going
to physically abuse you sexually abuse
you why does your mind always go to like
the worst possible it goes like no no
but I'm saying like like straight I
could think of many situations where
adoption worked out really well and like
my mom got pregnant when she was 17 and
she she could have thought you know my
life was over and she gave that kid up
for adoption he just got married he has
a kid now he grew up with a completely
different family yeah and well
fortunately for you see the good
unfortunately on my side where actually
because I I'm even for my demographic I
come from what I see and what is
actually a lot of what I feel like is
the masses most of the people that I
know that in those situations come from
very hard
um stories and backgrounds and when they
speak to me I can see how damaged they
are and how much pain they still feel
now because not everybody's even
equipped to learn how to heal themselves
so it's either we're going to create
this but they're alive but they're alive
but they're still suffering and this is
the thing right for example I'll give
you an example one of my my friend my
sister she has a friend she her parents
abused her her stepdad sexually abused
that she was on drugs she was 16. and
actually she had an accident and she
died and the friends were all very upset
they all really really sad and they
cried and everything but amongst them
they said you know what actually I feel
like she's in a better place because
this world was not treated and right her
situation was making him more depressed
and people are living by suffering
they're not living to live wait I think
that answers quickly is are you
religious I'm spiritual spiritual
they're I think that's a big part of it
I think what's happening now is
because I'm I'm spiritual I'm I don't
know what the [ __ ] I am but I'm not
saying that it is what I'm saying is I
think a big part of it is a lot of times
like I've I I don't believe in abortion
but I do not also think that I have the
right to tell a woman what to do with
her body so so what I think not that you
guys are this but I think that I think a
big part of it is that you
a lot of times I have aunts and people
who are very religious life is suffering
to them that's what it is one of the the
things and I think what you're arguing
no offense to you or anybody I think is
very different than what she's saying I
think it's a very two different points I
agree with zooby I agree with Auntie for
the most part uh both of you guys and I
also agree with you like I just said but
I think what you're getting at is from
your personal experience in life and
what you've been through and how you
came out of that experience versus
auntie in in
um zubi and pearl are coming from a
different Pearl talking about she had a
relative who was a sibling who was
raised in a wonderful world because they
were adopted I think you're coming from
your personal experiences of what you've
seen
yeah of course but that's life
perspective of experience I'm no not
usually I'm saying from her I'm saying
not you I'm just saying in general I
don't I don't think it's a religion this
thing no it's not a religious thing I'm
just saying in my head I go I just want
to know if she would say she was
spiritual religious because nine times
attended my per this is just my personal
experience when I talked to spiritual or
not really religious people they lean
towards her more and the religious
people lean towards this it does but
they're on both sides it happens but
what I'm saying is Pearl you're saying
you had a sibling raised beautifully out
of adoption right zubi saying he doesn't
believe in abortion is taking human life
Auntie's saying the same thing this
young woman is saying a very different
thing but it's based in her personal
experience in life and so on and so
forth which is okay I'm just saying I
don't believe in abortion but at the
same time I don't think I can tell a
woman or anybody what to do with their
person so I'm in this weird place of it
you're comfortable telling someone not
to kill someone all right
well for different reasons yes that's a
different podcast topic I'm comfortable
somebody's coming for me
about an innocent life we're not talking
about
innocent so for me I'm saying from my
background I can't
tell somebody not I mean I think is it
but for innocent live zooby I agree with
you I agree with you can anyone else
comment on whether they would because
the police yeah no I wanted to hear what
you would
oh why you bring me up
2.0 to be honest yeah I hear what
everyone's saying everyone has got like
um reasonable uh a reasonable standpoint
for what they're saying but me
personally like
um I I've done a tick tock where I said
um for instance one point broke people
shouldn't be having kids because you
bring kids into a life of struggle and
hardship see what I'm saying I think
especially someone like me who came from
um a background of struggle and hardship
like wearing hand-me-downs and all of
this and getting laughed and bullied and
all of that and stuff like that
um
some people just not meant to have kids
bro and your case is just mild you know
this in it what you're talking about
saying that you came from hardship yours
is mild in comparison yes I'm just
saying as from my experience and from
what I've seen like I've Got Friends
that like boom like their their parents
were crackheads like you know what I'm
saying like they just were waste men
waste women whatever and they've just
been freestyling through life and their
life has been hardship so like I get
where you're coming from 100 I get where
you're coming from because I came again
like my mom very very hard Pentecostal
Church Nigerian woman like bro like no
messing around in it like I'm saying so
I get I get where you're coming from and
where zooby's coming from it's an
innocent Life part it's just like well
at the end of the day everyone's gonna
have to answer for their own actions at
the end of the day I can't judge
somebody and say oh why did you do that
like bro like I don't know their
situation but some people know that bro
if I have a kid I'm gonna miss this
kid's life up bro
as many of you know I was just band on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible